hey guys and welcome back to the channel
today we are going to be talking about
mapreduce and while I haven't used
mapreduce too much in my young life I
have been doing a decent amount of just
reducing lately as I've managed to
reduce the number of girls that I'm
speaking to to zero this has been the
case for about the last year anyways
let's get into mapreduce okay if you
would believe it I just recorded this
entire thing without actually using my
iPad so now I have to do it again all
right so what is mapreduce well
basically mapreduce is also part of that
whole Hadoop distributed computing
environment and what it allows us to do
is perform these massive batch
computations on data that actually lives
in Hadoop and is basically already
stored in hdfs so how do we do this
what's so useful about mapreduce well a
couple of really big things for starters
as opposed to just like running a
massive SQL pipeline we can actually run
arbitrary code via defining a mapper and
reducer function we'll touch upon what
those mean in a little bit additionally
we can actually run computations on the
nodes that hold the data this is huge
for data locality
and it's really important in terms of
ensuring good performance and then
finally to kind of give you some of the
lore of mapreduce basically this thing
was created in the early 2000s and it
was created to basically run on servers
that were probably running other jobs or
other processes at the same time that
were a lot more important than the batch
jobs that mapreduce was running and so
as a result of that the entire system is
basically built to be super resilient to
failures where if you know just one node
or just one part of this batch job fails
we only have to restart that failed part
as opposed to restarting from scratch
which is hugely important when you have
so many failures and so many preempted
tasks
okay so let's move on to mappers and
reducers what are they if you're not
familiar with functional programming
maybe this will be useful for you
otherwise sorry for wasting your time so
let's imagine that I have like a
username or rather a bunch of usernames
and I have a message that they sent
and basically we want to say okay for
every single one of these username
message combos give me the user ID
and give me the length of the message
that's really all a mapper is doing it's
just some arbitrary function that takes
in an unstructured log and then spits
out some type of key value combo that
you basically want for every single line
of that log
should be simple enough the next one is
going to be a reducer so a reducer is
going to take many of the outputs from a
mapper all for the same key and it is
going to spit out just one value right
so rather than really list key value it
should kind of be a key and a list of
values
and what it's going to do is spit out a
single value
so in this case you know we can see the
key is going to be 21 the list of values
is going to be 15 10 and 5.
and what it's going to do is let's say
this is a reducer that computes the
average of those values so I'd say 15 10
5 you know take the sum of those and
then divide by 3 and that's how you get
10 and that is our value up there so
that's kind of what the reducer is doing
so basically by just defining a mapper
and reducer we can express all sorts of
complicated functionality and later in
the video I'll Express how to you know
do basically even more than that so
let's look at the actual mapreduce
architecture
effectively
I'm going to get rid of this here
because it was from the last time I
recorded sorry about that
imagine we've got these three nodes in
our Hadoop cluster
what this graph is basically showing is
through the stages of an individual
mapreduce job how the actual data looks
different on every single node so to
start we've got all this unformatted
data on disk
and basically the job there is to
convert it somehow to a more
standardized format that's useful to us
and obviously that's going to be the job
of the mapper so as you can see I've got
a bunch of different types of keys and
values that are mapped out of each log
line it's worth noting that if you see
something like K3 on two different nodes
that means they have the same key but
probably a different value
so we start with all of these mapped
values and then what we're actually
going to do is sort them and I'll
explain in a little bit while we do that
but the gist is that now that we have
all of these sorted values we can
perform this important step right here
which is the shuffle so how do we
actually decide you know something like
oh you know K3 from this node goes over
to node three well actually we would
take the hash of the key
and then we would basically go ahead and
send those down to the other node now
the reason that it's very nice that we
can actually have our keys be sorted is
because now what we're doing is sending
two sorted lists down to every single
node or actually even possibly multiple
sorted lists and now we can perform an O
of n merge join
because we want to keep our keys sorted
on the reducer and I'll explain why that
is on the next slide so again shuffling
is literally just partitioning it's
taking a hash of every single key and
sending it to the proper node so that it
can be reduced now remember that
reducing is basically saying okay we
have multiple values corresponding to
the same key
let's compress them down to just one
value so now we're running our reducing
function as you can see there's only one
k6 now with a certain value and before
there were two K sixes obviously in the
case of k19 there was only one key or
rather one value with k19 to begin with
so it's just going to stay like that in
the reduction phase and then finally the
entire point of mapreduce is to get data
that we can store back in hdfs and so as
a result the last step is materializing
and this is going to be in disk and then
go back to hdfs
get replicated all that good stuff so
again I keep mentioning that we were
doing some sorting because we want our
data on our reducer to be sorted so keep
in mind this guy is the reducer right
here so let's explain why we actually
want that let's imagine that this is my
reducer and the reduction function that
I want to do is perform the sum of the
values for each key so we have to
perform that in memory right so to start
it would be like oh a starts at 6. now
we're adding 8 to it so it's 14 and now
we're adding 10 to it so it's 24. since
we can now see oh B is three okay now I
no longer need to store the value 24 in
memory I can just say to disk because I
know that we're done Computing this
value since we started seeing a new key
same thing goes with B I can start with
3 then go to 10 and then go to 14 and
then I can flush it to disk
which is what mapreduce is eventually
going to do if our data is not sorted
then we don't actually know when we've
seen the end of a given key and we don't
know when we can flush to disk so it
would look something like this B is 3
now b is 7 oh wait now we have a is six
a is 16.
and then again B is now becoming 14 and
a is becoming 24. keep in mind that
there might even be a bunch more keys
here and yet we can't flush any of these
values to disk we have to keep them in
memory
and what that means is that if we have a
ton of keys it is a ton of extra memory
overhead which can really affect the
performance of our batch job which is
why it's so useful to keep things sorted
okay finally let's talk about Job
chaining so as of now we can just have
one mapper function and one reducer
function but what if we want more
advanced functionality than that well
keep in mind that every single mapreduce
job is literally just going from data on
disk to different data on disk and so
there's no reason that we can't take
this data right here and then do another
job where we go from data on disk to
data on disk and that's effectively what
we're doing right here in theory you can
just chain infinite mapreduce jobs
together you know it might obviously be
slow but it's worth noting that you can
do this and that's what a lot of people
will end up doing
so let's quickly conclude on mapreduce
so I can get myself into the gym
basically it is a super super useful
framework in terms of making big data
batch jobs that we eventually want to be
running on a schedule if we wanted to
run them in real time again that would
be more like stream processing but again
batch processing is something that's
still extremely common all the time we
have you know like daily jobs that we
want to be running and so something like
mapreduce is super useful we can express
even more complicated functionality in
mapreduce Via both data joins which
we'll probably cover in the next video
and also job chaining and then finally
it's worth noting that even though
mapreduce is an extremely fundamental
aspect of today's Computing landscape
in reality it's actually not used that
much and there are some pretty major
flaws with this design that make it a
little bit less feasible than some
Alternatives and of course within the
next few videos we'll be doing a deep
dive in that as well so stay tuned guys
I will see you in the next ones and have
a great night